you know him well will he be arrested
tomorrow I don't think he'll necessarily
be arrested tomorrow there may be
another witness before the grand jury
there are all kinds of technical things
that need to be done but I think it's a
matter of days before he will be
indicted he won't be arrested as such
but he has to surrender to authorities
to answer to the indictment and that
that could come this week whether it's
tomorrow I think is just it's just a
matter of time and how damaging would
that be well and his plans to be the
next president I think for Trump
unfortunately they're very positive and
for the Republican party it's bad news
because Trump is trying to persuade his
followers that he's being persecuted
that the prosecutor is a partisan
Democrat and if he's indicted he's
actually urged them to come into the
streets which is very dangerous I think
if Trump is indicted and acquitted it's
rocket fueled his campaign to get the
Republican nomination for president and
that's what gives rise to the theory
that many people even those who do not
support Trump think it's a democratic
conspiracy because Donald Trump is the
Democratic party's best asset if he's
nominated for the 2024 nomination in for
the presidency that will almost
guarantee a democratic win but if he's
written on his site protest protest
protest is that not potentially in
inciting violence well I think that's
exactly what he has in mind he saw what
he was able to do on January the 6th
2021 and I think there's a very real
risk this is what he wants this is the
kind of publicity that enables him to
say I'm being persecuted you're being
persecuted because of me it really feeds
on the animosity many people have toward
the toward the government but is that
not in itself an arrestable offense well
you know we have a First Amendment in
the United States you've got to go a
long way to say that somebody really is
inciting violence saying protest protest
protest we have a long history of
protests for perfectly good reasons so
Trump is covering himself and and we'll
have to see what happens I think the
real question is whether if he is
indicted he's convicted because I do
think that changes things two weeks of
testimony about how he paid hush money
to a porn star because of an
extramarital affair and then cook this
company's books but that's the that's
what is being indicted for isn't it it's
not paying the money it's it's uh
allegedly cooking the books it's
financial fraud and you know his base uh
in 2016 and 2020 consisted of a lot of
Evangelical Christians who wanted
conservatives nominated to the courts to
help overturn Roe v Wade that has now
happened I think two weeks of displaying
Stormy Daniels on television will help
move that base away from Trump so he has
risk here as well but the Democrats want
to see him nominated as the Republican
nominee uh and and this case would not
have been the first one brought if you
had one prosecutor looking at all the
things that are now being investigated
this may be the case most favorable to
Trump
Eve previously said sat here that you if
you don't think you'll run and if he
does run he won't win do you still think
so well I he's he is running now
um I think it's from having said he's
going to run to actually running it to
very and there's a there's a world of
difference that's right and he still
hasn't filed the necessary paperwork but
but what for Trump uh is absolutely
essential is a staying in the spotlight
and B not being a loser and it's the
fear of losing I think that could still
keep him out of the race actively uh
there are a number of other legal
investigations that are closing in on
them that are that are likely more
attractive to people around the country
to show that he's not fit to be
president uh the porn star Affair isn't
necessarily the one to do it and and and
that's a question if the prosecutors had
worked this out among themselves this
case might not be the one going forward
are you still going to run well I'm
still considering it for the reason that
I don't think Donald Trump is fit to be
president and I think his nomination uh
by the Republican Party party would be a
gift from God for the Democrats
I mean move on and talk about President
Putin he an arrest warrant for him uh
what's going to happen well nothing will
happen I I believe and have for many
years the international criminal court
is fundamentally illegitimate uh it's
not something the United States should
cooperate with why this is not in any
way to excuse Putin's conduct of the war
but there are jurisdictions that can try
him Ukraine in particular and ultimately
a free Russia to try them the
international criminal court is
illegitimate because it is an exercise
of governmental power in a vacuum
without any constitutional framework to
restrain it and it's a very dangerous
institution uh and I think the conduct
of the international criminal court is
potentially threatening at this point to
a diplomatic solution in Ukraine if you
want negotiations to take place do you
think an arrest warrant for Vladimir
Putin makes it more likely or less
likely he will negotiate this free
electron out there divorced from
political control and I mean that in the
Constitutional sense I just I think is
is is a more of a menace than a an A so
you have a beef with the ICC but do you
do you think if an arrest warrant was
issued by another Authority then that
you feel would be legitimate that that
would be appropriate well I think
Ukraine could certainly issue an arrest
uh warrant the issue though is do you
really want to try Vladimir Putin in
absentia that's the kind of stab in the
back circumstances that give rise to an
authoritarian being able to enhance his
own standing in domestic Politics the
real Ultimate Justice here for this is
going to have to come from a new Russian
government at some point and I think it
it inhibits the emergence of political
maturity when you tell a country in
whose name crimes have been committed
we're going to take the burden of
judging your leaders off you they are
precisely the people who should make
that judgment as Iraq made the judgment
to convict and execute Saddam Hussein hi
Twitchy should America be about the fact
that the Chinese president is going to
Moscow today well I think this is
further evidence of the Anton developing
into an axis between Moscow and Beijing
with China very much as the senior
partner I think it gives the lie to the
idea that China's kind of offended by
Russia's invasion in Ukraine that it's
trying to put distance between itself
and Russia China has been in Russia's
court on this from the get-go and this
is another affirmation of it Xi Jinping
may be trying to float a quote-unquote
peace plan but I will guarantee it'll be
a plan that while it may appear fair and
balanced on the surface is entirely
beneficial to Russia talking about heavy
weapons potentially being used
in the battle on the battlefield in
Ukraine well I think China has given
assistance to Russian men not Weaponry
not heavyweight but I think that's a
distinction without a difference if you
give resources money or other resources
that are fungible it just frees up
Russian resources to do more on heavy
weapons
um talk to me about the fact that it is
the 20th anniversary of the start of the
Iraq War
um speaking to Lord Ricketts who you may
want no no he um he was very much
involved at the time in the foreign
office do you feel
that it was a pointless warm no it was
absolutely the right thing to do and the
period of major combat operations
between today March 20th and May 1st uh
was an extraordinarily successful and
professional effort to remove Saddam
Hussein who was a threat to
International Peace and security by his
pursuit of nuclear weapons the fact that
Saddam Hussein is dead and that Iraq
does not have nuclear chemical or
biological weapons today is a huge
advance for uh for peace and security
around the world that you cannot treat
the 20 years from from 2003 to today as
a single block of granite everything
flowing from the from the decision to
invade in fact I would say the worst
mistake that the United States made and
we did make a number of mistakes there's
no doubt about it the worst mistake was
in 2011 when Barack Obama withdrew All
American forces from Iraq and and
eliminated the measure of stability
inside that country that in fact
facilitated the rise of Isis that
required Obama to go back in in 2014. I
think if we had stayed things would have
been substantially different and how
much of a mistake was it to withdraw
troops then from Afghanistan it was a
catastrophic strategic mistake we
created a vacuum in Central Asia that
China and Russia will try to fill it
enhance the possibility the terrorists
would once again go to Afghanistan which
is exactly what they're doing it
eliminated our ability to watch the
nuclear programs in Pakistan and Iran
from close up and what it's done to the
people of Afghanistan the women in
particular is is just incalculably
damaging okay let's head back West again
Moldova How concerned are you about that
well I'm very concerned about Moldova
and and the Russian efforts through the
so-called transnester Republic to
subvert the government I went to Moldova
in August of 2019 shortly before I
resigned from the white house because I
was concerned about what would happen to
it then and I think the invasion of
Ukraine by the Russians sets up the
possibility that they will try and
subvert the the government in Moldova
and be able to put even more Russian
troops on Ukraine's Western flank this
is an enormously important development
and it pre-sizes further Russian efforts
throughout the former Soviet Union to
recreate not the USSR but the Russian
Empire if their aggression in Ukraine is
not stopped and just moving even further
west back to your home country I think
you're heading back on Wednesday aren't
you um How concerned should the United
States be about these spy balloons
so-called spy balloons were you
overreacting there no I don't think we
were overreacting in fact I think the
Biden Administration should have shot
the balloon down as it crossed the coast
of Alaska a lot of speculation about
what this was all about but I think the
most likely is that China was trying to
consider what would happen in a crisis
or a period of hostilities when we
blinded their satellites in space and
they blinded ours these high altitude
balloons are a poor substitute for
satellites but they're better than
nothing and it occurs to me that we and
the West as a whole ought to be looking
at whether we need that capability why
do we need them though I mean apparently
there are satellites that can see car
number plates from space what's the
point in these fibroids because if in a
wartime situation anti-satellite weapons
destroyed that satellite capability you
would need Alternatives now we have the
U2 which is still one of the best spy
planes ever invented but the balloon
possibility is something I think we need
to think about more